there was an unexpected kind of hazard
you know of that job right so you're in
a small confined space the ring is 20
feet by 20 feet and you're with a group
of guys so you always want to try to
smell your best oh but here's the thing
we are a global touring company so we'll
do like a show in Shanghai and then come
back to San Francisco and do a show in
San Francisco and a lot of times and you
know this from from being a touring
musician sometimes travel gets messed up
sometimes flights get delayed so you can
like actually connect in Budapest land
in San Francisco and have to go to the
ring in two minutes
so everybody's given a few Mulligan's in
like the Biot in the breath category but
we also have a nice form of policing
ourselves where if somebody has a few
more Mulligan's than they should we kind
of give them the old hey man it's our
office out there could you kind of so
was your smell kind of a secret
strategies you ever smell on purpose
just to throw people off my thing in the
armpit kind of thing might actually that
it's decent all these years I've been
punching my way out of trouble but I
could have just smelled really bad oh
man where were you know my thing was
always Tic Tacs
it's like it's a nervous superstition
that I always have before we go on a
broadcast and I've had to wean myself
off of them because I would up to like
three boxes a day and it's right in the
20 minutes before broadcast it's it's
pretty much 10,000 calories and straight
sugar oh my gosh and you know what you
probably don't gain a pound do you John
well I have to go out and get beat up as
you saw about the photo okay you've
taught me something I need to go get
beat up and still working out I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
YouTube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this